mindfulness is very much in vogue at
this moment as as many of you probably
know and and it's often taught as though
it were a a glorified version of an
executive stress ball it's just it's a
what tool you want in your tool kit
prepares you emotionally to go into a
new experience with a positive attitude
and your knowing I'm you know hauling
around baggage from the past and that's
that's true it actually having focus and
having your mind in the present moment
is a it's a little bit of a superpower
in in situations that we're all in from
day-to-day but that actually undervalues
what mindfulness really is and it's its
true potential it's more like the Large
Hadron Collider and that it's a real
tool for making some fundamental
discoveries about the nature of the mind
and one of these discoveries that the
sense of self that we all carry around
from day to day is an illusion and and
cutting through that illusion I think is
actually more important than stress
reduction or any of the other
conventional benefits that that are that
are accurately ascribed to mindfulness
the enemy of mindfulness and really of
any meditation practice is being lost in
thought is this being is to be thinking
without knowing that you're thinking now
the problem is not thoughts themselves
we need to think we need to think to do
almost anything that makes us human to
reason to plan to have social
relationships to do science the thinking
is is indispensable to us but most of us
spend every moment of our waking lives
thinking without knowing that we're
thinking and this automaticity is I kind
of scrim thrown over the present moment
through which we view everything and it
and it's distorting of our lives it's
distorting of our emotions if it
engineers our unhappiness in every
moment because most of what we think is
quite unpleasant we're judging ourselves
we're judging others we're worrying
about the future we're regretting the
past where we're at war with our
experience in subtle or coarse ways and
much of this self-talk is unpleasant and
diminishing our happiness in every
moment so meditation is a tool for
cutting through that it's if we're
interrupting this this continuous
conversation we're having whether
selves so that is it's that in and of
itself is is beneficial but there are
there features of our experience that we
don't notice when we're lost and thought
so for instance every experience you've
ever had every emotion the the anger you
felt yesterday or a year ago isn't here
anymore it arises and it passes away and
if it comes back in the present moment
by virtue of your thinking about it
again it will subside again when you're
no longer thinking about it now that
this is something that people tend not
to notice because because we rather than
merely feel an emotion like anger we
spend our time thinking of all the
reasons why we have every right to be
angry and so and so the conversation
keeps this emotion in play for much much
longer than it would then it's a natural
half-life and if you if you're able
through mindfulness to interrupt this
conversation and simply witness the
feeling of anger as it arises you'll
find that you can't be angry for more
than a few moments at a time if you
think you can be angry for a day or even
an hour without continually
manufacturing this emotion by thinking
without knowing that you're thinking
you're mistaken and this and this is
something you can just witness for
yourself this is again this is an
objective truth claim about the nature
of subjective experience and it's it's
testable and mindfulness is the tool
that you would use to test it one
problem is that most of the people who
teach mindfulness and I know many of the
great the pasta teachers in the West and
in the east and have immense respect for
these people I learned to meditate in a
traditionally Buddhist context but most
people who teach mindfulness are still
in the religion business there's still
they're propagating Western Buddhism or
American Buddhism they're the connection
to the tradition of Buddhism in
particular is explicit and I think their
problems with that because one you if
you are declaring yourself a Buddhist
you are part of the problem of religious
sectarianism that is needlessly
shattered our world and I think we have
to get out of the religion business that
whatever is true about mindfulness and
that
and any introspective methodology that
will deliver truths about the nature of
consciousness is non-sectarian it's no
more Buddhist than physics is Christian
you know you know Christians invented
physics or discovered physics but no one
anyone talking about Christian physics
it clearly doesn't understand the
significance of what we've understood
through that that means it's the same
with meditation there's going to come a
time where we no longer are tempted to
talk about Buddhist meditation as
opposed to any other form it's just
we're just talking about turning
consciousness upon itself and what can
be discovered by that process it just so
happens that that Buddhism almost
uniquely has given us a language and a
methodology to do this in a way that is
really well designed for export to
secular culture because you can get to
the core truths of Buddhism the the
truth of selflessness the the ceaseless
impermanence of mental phenomenon the
the intrinsic unsatisfactoriness of
experience because you can't hold on to
anything that no matter how pleasant an
experience is it arises then passes away
and no matter how much you protect
yourself unpleasant experience is
destined to come these features of our
minds can be can be fully tested and
understood without believing anything on
insufficient evidence so it is true to
say that despite all the spooky
metaphysics and unjustified claims
within Buddhism you can get to the core
of it without any faith claim and
without without being intellectually
dishonest but it is intellectually
dishonest I think to keep talking about
these truths in an exclusively Buddhist
context because it's misleading it
subtly gives the message that in order
to have rich meaningful important
spiritual lives we must somehow continue
to endorse religious sectarianism we
must we must still frame
this inquiry with an ancient allegiance
to one accidental strand of human
culture as opposed to using all of the
concepts and tools and conversations
that are available to us in the 21st
century